cher nicolas sarkozy
chers amis
ce congrès fondateur marque un nouveau
départ pour notre mouvement politique
les républicains sont donc en route pour
l'alternance
depuis mai 2012 tout n'est que
renoncement le spectacle d'un
gouvernement qui n'a jamais cesser
d'affaiblir notre pays le gouvernement a
anesthésié la compétitivité de notre
économie il a découragé la capacité
d'innovation de nos entreprises il a
détourné les français du goût du travail
au profit de l'assistanat il a oublié
l'exigence qu'enseigne l'école qui dans
notre tradition républicaine
a toujours été le lieu de l'excellence
et du dépassement de soi et non celui du
nivellement il a enfin brisé sans
ménagement certains de nos repères
sociétaux au premier rang desquels la
famille qui sont pourtant l'héritage de
notre histoire et de nos racines
c'est donc aujourd'hui au coeur de ce
quinquennat des espérons qu'il nous faut
exprimer plus fortement que jamais nos
convictions c'est maintenant qu'il faut
transgresser le politiquement correct
qui nous faut avoir le courage de
désigner les maux dont souffre la france
le courage de réaffirmer avec simplicité
mais avec force ses constantes ce qui
constitue nos valeurs et le socle de
notre réflexion pour préparer 2017 oui
nous allons gagner les élections du
printemps 2017
j'en ai la conviction
nous avons reconquis le sénat met enfin
en septembre 2014 à l'hégémonie de la
gauche sur toutes les institutions de la
république nous avons gagné rassembler
les municipales nous avons gagné les
départementales et nous mettrons fin à
la mainmise des socialistes sur la
quasi-totalité des régions française en
décembre prochain j'en ai là aussi la
conviction
nous gagnerons les combats les combats
s'y qui s'annonce parce que unis unis
nous proposerons à nos concitoyens un
projet pour la france qui répondent à
leurs aspirations et qui doit traduire
une conception élevée du destin de notre
pays à ceux qui désespèrent parfois de
la politique et sont tentés de se
réfugier dans l'abstention ou pire dans
le vote protestataire
nous devons démontrer au cours de ces
deux prochaines années que non la droite
et la gauche ce n'est pas la même chose
et que le front national comme l'ont
rappelé à la fois bruno retailleau et
christian jacob c'est la pire des
solutions
la pensée de gauche n'est pas notre
référence nous ne portons dit les mêmes
valeurs ni la même compréhension de
l'économie ni le même projet ni la même
ambition pour la france le nouveau nom
de notre mouvement les républicains est
d'ailleurs devenu par le choix de nos
militants le signe intangible de notre
premier engagement nous devons avoir un
attachement il modéré et permanent pour
notre pays la france
partageons ce que disait renan en 1882
l'existence d'une nation est un
plébiscite de tous les jours comme
l'existence d'un individu est une
affirmation perpétuelle de la vie
nous devons constater que l'adhésion à
la république a été trop souvent
dissociés de l'attachement des nations
comment voulez vous que notre pays ne
connaissent pas aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des fractures que nous voyons devant
nous qu'elle soit ethnique
territoriale religieuse
aussi je la firme sans réserve mes chers
amis être républicain c'est d'abord
aimer sans retenue la france
être républicain
c'est faire passer cet attachement
devant toute chose en refusant de se
soumettre aux prétendus leçons de vertu
et de répondants ce qu'on voudrait nous
affliger et notamment nous infliger
cette gauche moralisatrice et soi disant
bien pensante
être républicain
c'est d'abord songé un intérêt des
français quand nous parlons sécurité
immigration politique étrangère voilà ce
qui nous distingue
nous les républicains de la gauche notre
nation a vécu de nombreuses épreuves par
le passé toujours comme le disait le
général de gaulle elle s'est redressée
n'ayons pas peur d'assumer notre récit
national nos racines l'apport des
lumières qui sont à la source de la
république française et de ses valeurs
monteront dans notre projet dans nos
ambitions dans chacun de nos actes nous
qui sommes pour un bon nombre aussi les
héritiers du gaullisme du christianisme
social du libéralisme la force de nos
héritages rassembler pour construire
l'avenir de notre pays c'est héritage
affirmons le en particulier dans la
défense de notre conception de la
laïcité toutes les religions je dis bien
toutes doivent trouver leur place dans
notre pays avec la primauté de la loi
civile fruit des lumières et de la
démocratie mais aussi avec le respect
mutuel voilà ce qui nous distingue
nous les républicains de la gauche ce
qui nous distingue aussi nous les
républicains de la gauche c'est
l'ambition que nous avons pour l'école
l'école comme le dit finkielkraut qui
doit permettre d'oublier sa communauté
d'origine et penser à autre chose qu'à
ce qu'il est pour pouvoir penser par
lui-même c'est ça qui doit nous
rassembler nous les républicains
l'école qui transmet des valeurs
les valeurs émancipatrice parce qu'elles
sont le fruit du travail
l'école qui restaure le mérite oui le
mérite que nous voulons c'est celui qui
consiste à permettre à chaque enfant
d'exprimer toute la richesse qu'il a en
lui ainsi il sera fier quel que soit son
métier il sera fier d'être couvreurs ou
d'être ingénieur il sera fier d'être
agriculteur il sera fier d'être ouvrier
car il sera fier de son pays la france
oui nous voulons une école
qui abolit tout esprit victimaire
pour nous les républicains la réponse
sera toujours la liberté sur bruno
retailleau le choix la responsabilité
l'ouverture au monde
l'épanouissement par le travail voilà ce
qui nous distingue nous les républicains
de la gauche enfin je voudrais vous
parler des institutions chacun le sait
je suis très attaché aux institutions de
la vème république
elles se sont adaptées mais n'ont jamais
failli et des crises aux attentes à 2
janvier dernier et bien nos institutions
qui ont permis à l'exécutif de protéger
les français les apôtres de la sixième
république nous replongerait vers
l'instabilité et de deshors enfin
je voudrais le dire en tant que
président de l'institution qui
représente l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales nous avons un besoin
impératif en ces temps de désarroi du
filet des 550 mille élus locaux qui sont
la solidité et la cohésion de la
république affirmant le n'ayons pas peur
n'ayons pas peur c'est pas faire mode
que de croire qu'il faut les réduire
alors
je le dis il nous faudra rassembler
maurice leroy nous l'a rappelé il y à un
instant où il faudra rassembler mais en
même temps il faudra rassembler non pas
sur l'ambiguïté mais rassembler sur des
valeurs partagées par assemblée
uniquement dans une espèce de coalition
électorale mais dans une coalition pour
la france car la seule chose qui compte
c'est la france alors mes chers amis je
veux dire un nicolas à nicolas sarkozy
les attentes et les espoirs que nous
portons dans son action il a su nous
fédérer la tête de notre mouvement nous
serons je serai à ses côtés pourrait
écrire cette nouvelle page des
républicains je voudrais le remercier
très sincèrement devant vous et chacun
connaît ma liberté de ton
permettez moi parce que trop s'il ira de
dire à valérie pécresse
que je suis sûr qu'elle va nous conduire
à la victoire en ile de france au
printemps prochain tout comme bruno
retailleau dans les pays de la loire
tout comme l'ensemble de l'hôtel police
il faut vous gagnez c'est essentiel pour
la france puis viendront les primaires
qui seront un moment de respiration
démocratique
elles nous donneront aux force et
légitimité au candidat que nous aurons
choisis et derrière lequel je vous le
dis nous nous rassemblerons tous ce sera
de voir une fois le choix fait d'être
ensemble réunis pour la victoire nous le
devons à la france
alors chers amis avec les républicains
donnons un nouvel espoir à la france je
vous le dis à la france et aux français
la france ne peut plus attendre avec les
républicains vive la france